des travaux que nous avons décidés au
printemps dernier et nous accueillons
aujourd'hui madame Michel pati madame
merci de de votre présence je vous
rappelle à chacun et chacune d'entre
vous que cette audition est publique à
savoir qu'elle est
retransmise sur les réseau du Sénat mais
également ouverte au public à la presse
et à tous ceux qui s'intéressent à nos
travaux nous avons prévu 1h30 d'horloge
à peu près et donc chacun pourra
évidemment s'exprimer s'il le souhaite
après que nous ayons pu entendre madame
paaty je voudrais peut-être rappeler
avant de laisser la parole au président
Lafond que il y a seulement 4 jours au
lycée Gambetta d'Arras Dominique Bernard
professeur de lettrre a été
assassiné professeur d'éducation
physique et sportive un agent
d'entretien et le chef d'équipe
technique de l'établissement ont
également été blessés tous tentaient de
protéger leurs collègues et leurs élèves
contre un assaillant dont les
motivations islamistes ne font plus de
doute ou ne font Guer de doute cet
attentat entendait-il entendait
semble-t-il prolongé celui survenu il y
a 3 ans qui a conduit à l'assassinat de
Monsieur Samuel
paatti cet attentat vient ainsi
cruellement illustrer l'actualité de la
question que nos deux Commission on
souhaité traiter la commission des
affaires culturelles de l'éducation et
des sports ainsi que la commission des
lois de manière commune en créant cette
mission de
contrôle le pour contrôler le traitement
les signalement et le traitement des
pressions et les pressions pardon qui
sont menaces et agressions dont les
enseignants sont victimes
pardon nous entendons madame nous
entendons aujourd'hui vous êtes la sœur
de Monsieur Samuel pati vous aviez je le
rappelle ici adressé un courrier au
président du Sénat lequel président du
Sénat et à moi-même d'ailleurs et nous
avons décidé avec le président la fond
de mettre en place cette mission notre
audition était prévu de longue dates je
le redis qu' transmise en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté de témoigner
devant nous j'ai néanmoins déjà eu
l'occasion de le préciser lors de nos
auditions de cet été et c'est important
pour que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
mesure bien la portée de notre travail
cette mission d'information ne peut se
pencher sur des faits qui font l'objet
d'une enquête en cours j'insiste si tel
était le cas évidemment la mission
prendrait fin immédiatement
naturellement elle a vocation à se
pencher en revanche sur les mécanismes
devant permettre de prévenir
l'occurrence de tel DRAM à l'avenir
malheureusement bien sûr nous venons de
le revivre trop récemment notamment
l'évaluation et le traitement des
menaces dans ce cadre votre témoignage
madame évidemment sur ce qui s'est passé
il y a 3 ans et qui reste dans nos
mémoires est absolument essentiel je
vais laisser la parole au président
Laffond et à la fin de son intervention
parce que nous sommes sous forme de
commission enquête euh je devrais vous
demander de prêter serment mais je vais
d'abord laisser le président de la fond
président de la fond la parole merci mes
chers collègues comme vient de le
souligner le président buffet cette
audition s'inscrit dans un contexte
pesant le le drame qui s'est déroulé
dans l'enceinte du lycée Gambetta d'aras
est venu bratellement nous nous rappeler
la menace que font planer
l'obscurantisme et et le fanatisme sur
nos sociétés il nous rappelle également
que les écoles lieu de transmission de
savoir et de formation à la citoyenneté
sont devenus une cible pour les
intéchristes islamiste avant de débuter
cette audition nous avons bien entendu
une pensée pour Dominique Bernard
lâchement assassiné pour sa famille ses
proches ainsi que pour les personnels de
l'Éducation nationale blessé vendredi à
aras nous tenons aussi à vous remercier
Madame Paty d'avoir accepté de venir
témoigner devant nos commissions au
moment où cette ravive des souvenirs
douloureux pour l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative et bien sûr pour
vous-même vos différentes prises de
paroles ont été scruté et commenté
depuis l'assassinat de votre frère hier
vous êtes intervenu 3 ans jour pour jour
après le drame au sein du collège
François Girou à Vincenne et sur la
scène du théâtre de l'uvre pour
prononcer des mots particulièrement
poignant certaines de de vos sorties se
sont avéré tristement monitoire comme
lorsque vous déclariez il y a 15 jours
dans Marianne que nous n'étions pas dans
l'après Samuel pati mais dans le pendant
d'autres raisonnent avec une acuité
toute particulière comme lorsque vous
déclariez à l'occasion de la remise d'un
prix créé en l'honneur de votre frère
qu'enseigner c'est expliquer et non se
taire je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui un
enseignant sur deux déclare dans notre
pays s'autocensuré par peur de
contestation d'enseignement c'est dans
ce contexte que nous conduisons cette
mission commune de contrôle destinée non
pas à juger des faits tâche qui relève
comme l'a rappelé le président buffet de
procédure judiciaire en cours mais à les
comprendre à les mettre en perspective
et apprécier également si la situation a
évolué depuis 3 ans afin de formuler
évidemment des propositions visant à
améliorer la réactivité et l'efficacité
des services publics concernés qu'il
s'agisse de la police de la justice ou
de éducation nationale nous essayons à
notre tour et dans notre rôle
d'expliquer et de ne pas nous taire pour
prévenir non plus l'occurrence mais la
multiplication des drames nous allons
donc vous écouter attentivement dans
quelques instants madame Paty non sans
vous avoir préalablement informé comme
l'a fait le président buffet que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site du
Sénat bien je voudrais rappeler aux
collègues donc je vous ai indiqué qu'on
avait 1h30 on peut jusqu'à 2h nous
sommes nombreux bien sûr les prises de
parole doivent être signalées pour qu'on
puisse les enregistrer et se partager
entre la commission des lois et la
commission de l'éducation naturellement
et nous limitons le temps d'intervention
à 2 minutes si on veut que tout le monde
puisse pouvoir puisse s'exprimer
naturellement avant de passer la parole
madame je dois vous rappeler que nous
nous sommes dotés des pouvoirs de
commission d'enquête et qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait pasible des peines
prévues par les dispositions des
articles 400 34- 13-1 et- 15 du code
pénal je vous invite à prêter serement
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et de dire je le jure je le
jure merci Madame et bien vous avez la
parole et nous vous
écoutons je dédie ce texte à Monsieur
Dominique Bernard professeur assassiné
ce vendredi 13 octobre 2023 lors d'une
attaque terroriste islamique mettant à
exécution les ordres de ceux qui veulent
détruire notre école pour détruire notre
démocratie oui je dédie ce texte à celui
qu'on n pas sauvé Monsieur Dominique
Bernard messieur les président François
Noël buffet et Laurent Laffond mesdames
et messieurs les
sénateurs je viens tout d'abord vous
remercier pour l'ouverture de cette
mission de contrôle parlementaire doté
des pouvoirs de commission d'enquête
afin de comprendre les failles
administratives et politiques qui ont pu
concourir à l'assassinat de Samuel
paatti d'analyser les mesures
correctives qui en ont découlé et d'
tirer les évidentes
recommandations en voulant vous écrire
ces quelques mots je me suis retrouvé
face à l'angoisse de la page blanche et
j'ai compris qu'en fait cette angoisse
ne vient pas que l'on ait rien à dire
mais au contraire de ce qu'il y a trop à
dire je me suis ensuite perdu dans les
méandres du politiquement correct où à
trop mettre les formes on en oublie le
fond il a fallu revenir à l'essentiel je
dirais même aux fondamentaux le simple
le fait qu'un professeur a pu être
décapité pour blasphème en France en
2020 démontre que faille il y a cette
enquête je vous ai demandé de l'amener
au nom de Samuel paatti mon frère il
faut partir du singulier pour comprendre
ce qui nous regarde tous car partir de
tous ne n perra jamais de comprendre le
destin tragique d'un homme d'un
professeur mon frère Samuel pati je
vient effectivement vous presser
d'investiguer bien au-delà du cercle
d'imputabilité défini par la justice la
justice traite le crime en fonction du
champ des possibles mais la vérité
judiciaire ne condamne que ce qui est
pénalement répréhensible et néglige la
responsabilité politique celle qui prône
le respect des droits fondamentaux
l'ordre républicain et l'intérêt commun
cette vérité et réalité dont je vous
parle est celle qui est mise entre
guillemets et minimisé par tous ceux qui
se retrouvaient face à leur
responsabilité s'ils devaient
l'affronter sans phare ce comportement
d'irresponsabilité illimité est légitimé
par une meute de courtisan prêt à toutes
les compromissions en délivrant des
certificats de probité sans sans examen
de conscience il est également encouragé
par l'attribution de promotion et de
décoration même S a Yu échec ou fiasco
ce qui donne le sentiment à ceux qui les
reçoivent d'avoir fait ce qui doit être
fait et procure une unité de fait à ceux
qui les distribuent les inconséquences
qui en découlent renforcent la méfiance
et la défiance d'un peuple qui ne
recroit plus en ses
représentants ce renoncement à
l'intégrité non par incapacité
intellectuelle ne permet plus de mettre
en harmonie la parole et les actes il
n'y a plus que cette probité de façade
qui laisse ouvertes des brèches immenses
permettant la réalisation des actes les
plus odieux c'est bien ce contexte là
que l'absurde est devenu réalité mon
frère a été décapité le 16 octobre 2020
3 ans après il est temps de réaliser que
la fameuse phrase lancée par Monsieur
Blanquer il y aura un avant et un après
Samuel pti n'a pas eu les effets
attendus cet après qui laisse régner la
violence pour clore tout débat et ainsi
Infiné imposer le respect des croyances
et non plus des croyants basculant ainsi
d'une démocratie laïque à une théocratie
le billon est définitivement obtenu en
adjectivant le mot laïcité afin d'en
dénaturer le sens et de la transformer
en une injonction à
l'athéisme si la référence n'est plus la
loi mais le fait de ne pas offenser
certains musulmans qui mettent leur
carateur au-dessus de tout de la justice
comme de la fraternité cela n'entraînera
que censure et mancablement une
application différenciée des règles en
fonction de l'appartenance religieuse
octroyant finalement plus de droit à
certains véritable ferement de discorde
et de
séparatisme prenez la tolérance et
invoquez toujours plus de bienveillance
sousentendant ainsi que le professeur
pourrait être malveillante par nature
n'a pourtant ouvert la voie qu'à des
dérives incontrôlables et finalement au
renforcement des extrêmes face à
l'ineefficacité il faut peut-être cesser
de dire que c'est le résultat qui est
erroné et bien plutôt de reconnaître que
c'est la méthode qui est mauvaise
je vous invite à essayer de mettre le
mot empathie à la place de bienveillance
juste essayer en adoptant la perspective
d'autruie la culture de l'empathie
favorise la lutte contre l'harcèlement
comme Monsieur Atal a pu le dire les le
mois dernier mais pour répondre au
détracteur de cette idée cela ne se
résume pas à cela cette attitude
favorise également un climat scolaire
propice aux apprentissages conforte le
le respect de la pluralité des opinions
et permet de se prémunir des pensées
dogmatiques il y a plusieurs formes
d'empathie l'empathie émotionnelle est
la seule capable d'induire un comp
moral c'est celle qu' a utilisé dans le
courir de mon frère la notion de bien et
de mal est le plus souvent acquise ce
qui manque cruellement c'est de
reconnaître émotionnellement les
préjudices ou douleurs causé ce qu'on
appelle la responsabilité morale
d'ailleurs le Danemark l'a bien compris
puisque les cours d'empathie il sont
obligatoires depuis une loi de
1993 donc de 6 à 16 ans ils reçoivent
une heure d'empathie par semaine et ces
enfants ont la chance d'accès à ses
cours pour leur bien-être et le
bien-être de
tous sans impathie sans cette capacité
il est impossible de comprendre les
principes de la laïcité et les valeurs
de la République ni même celles de la
liberté d'expression sans impathie on
accorde aucun crédit à la vie de l'autre
l'autre étant relégué au rang d'ennemis
ce n'est pas nécessaement le contenu des
réseaux sociaux qui pose un problème
mais bien la culture de la tête baissée
qui nous ferme au monde par un repli
narcissique et nous empêche de dépasser
la peur de l'inconnu l'empathie permet
de rétablir qui est victime et qui est
bourreau et non d'avoir à se confronter
avec des bourreaux prétendument victimes
car c'est
ainsi excusez-moi qu' ou finit avec des
qu'on finit avec des crimes sans
coupable voire avec des victimes un peu
responsables l'éducation à l'empathie
restaure le sens du mot fraternité je
citerai monsieur Omar Zana docteur en
sociologie et en psychologie professeur
des université en sciences de
l'éducation au men l'empathie cela
s'éduque certes la disposition à
l'empathie est inhérente à l'espèce
humaine mais si elle n'est pas éduquée
elle ne se développe pas je pense
également qu'il serait salvateur que
parents et personnel à tout niveau de
l'institution en en bénéficie
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on devient après ça
c'est bien cette question que je me suis
posé le lendemain de sa mort il va bien
falloir que j'en fasse quelque chose de
ce ça un S sans nom juste un visuel à
l'Institut médico légal où ma réaction
première a été de dire ce n'est pas lui
je crois que je voulais pas que ce corp
meurtri soit celui de mon frère ce ça
inomable ne prendrait sens que lors que
j'aurais eu toutes les vérités même
celle dont je n'aurais pas voulu qu'elle
soit vraie en règle générale nous
choisissons nos vérités mais dans C cas
on observe que c'est pas nous qui
choisissons nos vérités mais ce sont les
vérités qui nous choisissent c'est ce
qui se passe quand certains veulent nous
imposer leur vérité celles qui sont
agréables et rassurantes pour eux pas
pour
moi je crois que c'est ce qui s'est
passé le 3 décembre 2020 à la lecture du
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation du sport et de la Recherche
ce rapport s'intitule avec une sobriété
forcée et anonyme enquête sur les
événements survenus au collège du boison
Conflant saint-honorine retirant à mon
frère la plus simple dignité celle que
cette enquête soit menée en son nom ici
on parle de gérer un trouble le régime
du trouble étant le cours sur la liberté
d'expression de Samuel pati la
formulation choisie trahit l'intention
véritable de ce travail il s'agit non de
faire la lumière sur la responsabilité
des éventuelles erreurs des uns et des
autres dans cette affaire mais avant
tout de dédoiner l'institution de toute
responsabilité éventuelle on
s'interrogera sur la conception très
particulière du dialogue que cette
mission d'inspection a pu avoir avec les
acteurs du terrain seul trois
professeurs sur ont été entendus sur les
51 qui composent l'équipe pédagogique
versus versus quat représentants des
parents d'élèves inversant ainsi le
rapport de force on pourrait également
s'interroger sur la rapidité de sa
rédaction le rapport ayant été bouclé ou
baclé en 15 jours ce qui ne laisse
d'interroger sur le but attendu je tiens
également à souligner la volonté
constante de l'éducation nationale à
travers ce rapport de faire totalement
abstraction d'une quelconque notion de
péril grave et imminent comme ce fut le
cas la semaine précédent l'attentat et
de continuer de transformer une campagne
islamique en problème
pédagogique cette procédure utilisé sans
doute pour empêcher tout exercice du
droit de retrait le cas échéant pour
celui qui oserait en telles circonstance
se retirer devenant bien évidemment un
excusez-moi un abandon de poste avec une
menace de
radiation on pourrait aussi soulever les
mécanismes du non dit de l'éducation
nationale là parle d'élèves et de
familles compliqué jamais difficile ou
tout simplement impossible à gérer et
refusant de s'insérer dans la société
française l'administration préfère juger
que les professeurs sont en difficulté
et que les chefs d'établissement sont
insuffisants il me semble également
nécessaire d'évoquer les excuses qu'on a
demandé à Samuel de formuler auprès de
ses élèves ce comportement donne tout
pouvoir aux parents d'élèves qui ont un
compte à régler avec l'institution on se
retrouve avec des élèves victimes et
s'il n'avit pas encore pensé on les
désigne obligeamment comme tel et le
professeur devenant coupable aux yeux de
tous même de certains de ses collègues
l'un d'eux faisant du Zè pour l' cabler
se mettra en scène devant ses classes de
3e ce qui aura sur certainement motivé
ceux-ci à se retrouver à 17h le 16
octobre 2020 pour les vrai mon frère à
son bourreau ce petit professeur
meurtrrié d'avoir perdu son tit de
coordinateur de matière au profit de mon
frère il adaptera à son tour une posture
victimaire aour au retour des vacances
de tous sain sans doute victime de ses
collègues spectateurs complices qui se
sont inventé une conscience
post-attentat et qui pourtant ne voyait
rien à redire à son comportement avant
quand il aurait fallu resserrer les
rangs le comble viendra lorsque lui
bénéficiera de la mise en retrait
d'éducation nationale peu après la
rentrée du 2 novembre
2020 même lorsque le 9 octobre 2020 la
viérité éclatera c'est-à-dire l'absence
de la petite menteuse dans le cours
incriminé tout le monde sans exception
continuera à propager la calomnie et
traitera mon frère en coupable
l'imaginaire c'est donc subsit situé au
réel revenons maintenant sur le comptage
des attatements Suel à la laïcité sans
doute un terme pudique pour ne pas
parler d'offensive islamique l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur papendia pour justifier ses
chiffres préfère parler de la culture du
finalemement afin de minimiser la
gravité du phénomène il précise tout de
même qu'il y aura deux pics annuels l'un
pendant le Ramadan et un autre en
octobre lié à l'attentat contre mon
frère ce qui confirme à demi mot qu'il
s'agit bien de revendication identitaire
de la mouvance islamiste monsieur
papendia don également le ton il s'agit
de phénomène inéluctabl auquel il faudra
bien s'habituer tout en se refusant
d'admettre que le nombre réel
d'atteintes à la lécité est sousévaluer
que nombre de faits ne sont pas signalés
et qu'il y a une recrudesence depuis
l'attentat de mon frère à quoi ce à quoi
cela sert-il de jouer le jeu de la
transparence sans même reconnaître que
l'on n en nos troubles les remontées des
atteintes à la laïcité relèvent de la
responsabilité des chefs d'établissement
celles-ci sont rédigées sur une fiche
fait établissement relevant du niveau 3
c'est-à-dire fait d'une extrême gravité
et entraîne obligatoirement une réaction
de l'institution comme nous le montre la
fiche résumée respect du principe de
laalcité prévenir répondre
soutenir il convient de rappeler que
contrairement à ce que Monsieur papendi
ait pu dire dans son édition auprès de
vous le 4 juillet dernier tous les faits
de niveau 1 à 3 remontent au mystère et
que le niveau 4 relève du National et ne
peut donc être prononcé au niveau
académique pour les niveaux 2 et 3 sont
alertés lia d'zen le recteur les
référents justice et l'équipe mobile de
sécurité pour le cas spécifique du
niveau 3 le chef d'établissement doivent
au préalable prendre attache
téléphonique auprès du dazen ou du
daazen le cas échéant avant toute
retranscription de l'événement sur la
fiche fait établissement les chefs
d'établissement se retrouvent à devoir
faire une courte narration des faits
spécifier s'il peut y avoir un
retentissement médiatique paramètrre
important que je vous demande de noter
pour plus tard et remplir de case
victime et coupable
présumé comment retire-t-on l'octroit de
la protection fonctionnelle c'est assez
simple il suffit juste de remplir la
case victime par l'expression groupe
d'élèves et la case coupable par
personnel de l'établissement et ainsi c
le rend la faute personnelle imputable à
l'agent ce qui est donc un obstacle à
l'oroit de la protection fonctionnel et
même s'il en fait la demande elle lui
sera refusé document à l'appui même
cette protection dérisoire a été retirée
à mon
frère
je m'interrogerai le je m'interrogeais
le 9 décembre 2022 lors d'une de mes
interventions dans le cadre de la j de
laicité sur le fait qu'on laisse encore
le soin aux chefs d'établissement de
définir si tel ou telle tenu sont
ostensiblement religieuses ce
comportement n'avait pour effet que de
mettre dos à dos ceux qui les tolèent
les gentils et ceux qui s'y opposent les
méchants les abayas les Camille même le
voile affichent ostensiblement
l'appartenance religieux islamique de
ceux qui les portent il n'y a pas besoin
de savoir si ces tenue vestimentaire
s'accompagne de discours ou d'attitude
qui conteste la laïcité et s'il s'agit
d'un comportement prilite ou
communautariste le simple fait de les
porter est un acte de défiance vis-à-vis
de la règle commune il s'agit ni plus ni
moins d'un appel à la désobéissance
civile la règle commune est ce qui donne
la structure à une société sans
structure la société s'écroule je ne
peux que féliciter Monsieur hatal de
rejoindre mes convictions et de prendre
clairement position en renonçant avec la
practique du Cap par cas qui prévalait
avant la loi de 2004 il faut arrêter de
croire que ceux qui ne respectent pas la
lité n'en comprennent pas le sens ils le
comprennent trop bien et c'est pour cela
qu'il veulent la détruire le tout ce
n'est pas de parler de chantier comme la
martelé monsieur le Président Macron ce
24 juillet dernier avec des travaux de
rénovation coûteux pour réparer les
défauts visibles négligeant les fils
cachés et bien de définir s'il s'agit
d'un chantier de construction ou de
démolition à ce stade je voudrais
également soulever un problème qui s'est
aggravé à la suite de l'attentat contre
mon frère les enseignants quittent
massivement le navire éducation
nationale
selon un rapport de la commission des
finances du Sénat sur le budget 2022 la
crise des démissions continue de
s'aggraver mettant en évidence une pque
croissante d'enseignants qualifiés entre
2020 et 2022 le nombre de démission est
passé de
3959 à
39270 soit une augmentation de 26 %. en
outre il faut ajouter les quelques
200000 départs à la retraite chaque
année qui ne sont pas remplacés
intégralement par le recrutement sur
concours cette année scolaire 2023-2024
ce t plus de 16 % des postes au concours
qui sont restés vacants soit 3100 postes
non pourvus
supplémentaires la conséquence immédiate
de ces crises est l'obligation pour le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale de
faire appel à des contractuels non
formés il convient alors de s'interroger
sur les modalités de recrutement
notamment quand on sait que Monsieur
sifrioui le fichier s mis en examen pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminels dans l'assassinat de mon frère
a été maître auxiliaire en informatique
pour éducation nationale pendant 15 ans
à
Paris les conséquences sont que les
enseignants restant se retrouvent avec
des classes surchargées altérant ainsi
la capacité de dispenser un enseignement
de qualité ce qui pénalisera
inévitablement en priorité les élèves
les alternatives proposées pour palier
également à l'absentéisme consistent
soit à demander aux enseignants un
fonctionnement en astintre dans le cadre
du PACT enseignant soit à faire assurer
par les assistants d'éducation
enseignement appelés surveillant un
cours par support numérique fourni par
éducation nationale comme monsieur hatal
l'a annoncé à sa nomination à son poste
actuel de ministre d'éducation nationale
tout le monde connaît l'expression qui
peut le plus peut le moins en procédure
dégradée c'est qui peut le moins fait ce
qu'il peut ce ni la qualité ni la
pédagogie qui est attendue c'est le fait
de fournir un service minimum en mode
dégradé il y a toujours une certaine
tolérance sur les
pertes je parlerai enfin de la censure
évoquée par l'ancien ministre lui-même
plus d'un professeur sur deux ça vous
sêtes déjà autant censuré enquête hiop
décembre 2022 pour reprendre ses propos
il serit y avoir d'omerta dans
l'éducation nationale et je su
intraitable à ce sujet qu'est-ce que
cela veut dire concrètement le ministère
sanctionnerait-il celui qui n'applique
pas le programme mais quel est le
soutien de l'institution quand un
professeur relève le défi d'assurer son
programme il faut bien reconnaître que
défendre les valeurs républicaines et
bel et bien une prise de risque la
menace de se prendre une Samuel pati est
devenue une l'arme de toute censure
islamique la circulaire de l'éducation
nationale a intitulé plan cité dans les
écoles et établissements scolaires du 9
novembre 2022 tente d'apporter une
réponse le premier volet consiste à
sanctionner systématiquement et de façon
graduée le comportement des élèves
portant atteinte à la laïcité lorsqu'il
persistent après une phase de dialogue
c'est mal connaître ces jeunes de penser
qu'un rappel à l'ordre à la loi sert à
quelque chose ce qui est perçu comme une
sanction pour l'éducation nationale est
perçu tout au plus comme une humiliation
aux yeux de cette jeunesse qui n'accorde
aucun crédit à l'autorité ces sanctions
qui ne débouchent sur rien développent
un sentiment d'impunité et entraîn
récidive ou vengeance on traite les
symptômes sans traiter le mal le
problème est l'absence générale
d'autorité envers cette jeunesse qui n'a
plus de limite et qui donc ni ne peut ni
ne veut faire société l'école ne peut
pas lier la carence de figure
représentant l'autorité auprès de ses
jeune mais il faut lui rendre celle qui
lui est propre pour cela il faut que
l'institution endosse les rôles qui lui
incombent c'est-à-dire sa capacité à
prendre sous sa responsabilité les
sujets les plus sensibles il faut
également que cette même institution
répond du traitement erroné et de la non
protection qui en a découlé dans le
dossier de mon frère sinon pourquoi les
enseignants prendrai-ils le risque de
défendre les valeurs républicaines s'ils
ne sont pas assurés d'être protégés et
ainsi rassurés il faut restaurer une
république au comportement ferme sur ces
principes exemplaires et responsables
alors on pourra parler d'autorité
légitime et ainsi obtenir l'adhésion par
respect et non par soumission en
infantilisant ou en manipulant le
sentiment de
peur perdre l'école ce n'est pas perdre
une bataille ni offrir une prise de
guerre à l'adversaire c'est perdre la
guerre il convient maintenant de se
pencher sur ce qui a été mis en place du
côté du ministère de l'Intérieur il y a
tout d'abord Faros cette plateforme
censé effectuer une veille sur les
réseaux sociaux en s'appuyant notamment
sur des signalements émis par les
citoyens quelques mois après l'attentat
qui a coûté sa vie à mon frère dans
l'émission La Fabrique du mensonge j'ai
pu voir Monsieur Laurent Nunez alors
coordinateur national du renseignement
et de la lutte contre le terrorisme se
féc C d'avoir triplé les effectifs de
Faros soit un peu plus de 90 policiers
et gendarmes cela pourrait passer pour
une bonne nouvelle si les signalements
entre 2020 et 2021 n'avait pas triplé
également ce qui revient donc
mathématiquement au même il convient
aussi de s'interroger sur les capacités
et modalités d'analyse des données et
sur le traitement qui en découle que
dire également des réseaux sociaux qui
semble être devenu le lieu privilégié de
la calomnier toutes les propagandes le
travail de modérateur de ces médias
semble fortement limité sans même que
nous en comprenions véritablement les
critères je vous signale également qu'il
a fallu plus de 3 mois pour que je
parvienne par le biais de mon avocate à
faire supprimer la vidéo de Monsieur
schnina mis en examen pour assistance
d'un projet terroriste contre mon frère
par facebook France étrangement Faros
qui pourtant cette fois avait reçu de
nombreuses finalement n'a pas uvré ou
n'a pas pu la faire
supprimer je verse maintenant à mon
témoignage quatre articles de presse
écrite premier
article article de libération du 17
octobre 2020 intitulé Conflant une note
de renseignement retrace la chronologie
des jours précédents l'attentat article
de Marianne 28 octobre 2020 intitulé
dans les ivblines la grande
compromission d'élu avec l'islam radical
article du Parisien du 30 octobre 2020
intitulé après l'attentat de Conflant le
Conseil des instances musulmanes des
ivelines dans la tourmente article de la
Gazette en iveline du 13 novembre 2020
intitulé mis en cause le SIMI répond à
ses
détracteurs je me livrerai à une
extraction d'éléments factuels de ces
articles les renseignements territoriaux
des ivelines dépendent de la Direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur
autrement appelé
rt78 ils ont rédigé une note datée du 12
octobre 2020 soulignant que je cite la
communication a visiblement permis
d'apaiser les tensions et que pour
l'heure les responsables de la
communauté musulmane locale ne se sont
pas manifestés alors que visiblement de
son propre aveu lu Simi conseil des
institutions musulmanes des ivelines
avait eu connaissance de la faire des
caricatures que je
cite des démarches amiables avaient eu
lieu et que la situation s'était apaisée
et cela avant le 16 octobre le SIMI
s'attribue un rôle de médiateur entre la
communauté musulmane et l'État monsieur
Abdelaziz El jaourri ancien secrétaire
du Simi déplore que je cite nos
instances ont failli avant l'attentat
car n'ont pas permis d'éteindre la
polémique et d'intervenir auprès de ce
père de famille il mentionnera également
avoir reçu la vidéo du père donc
monsieur schnina le 12 octobre 2020 par
un des membres du Simi le SIMI ne
désavouera pas qu'il y ait eu partage de
vidéo mais parlera je cite d'une pure
erreur matérielle en condamnant cet acte
à postériori le SIMI a conclu avoir
rempli sa part du contrat comme il le
dit en effectuant des démarche amiaable
et en constatant que la situation était
apaisée quelle était donc la nature du
contrat quels ont été les critères
objectifs pour dire que la situation
était apaisée ce mot apaisé et cette
analyse fallacieuse se retrouveront
ensuite tel quel dans la note des rt78
du 12 octobre 2020 et dans le rapport du
référent en laïcité daté du 12 octobre
2020 que vous pourvez retrouver dans le
rapport de
l'IGR maintenant il me semble important
de revenir sur le terme de
médiateur je me pose effectivement des
questions sur l'impartialité d'une
organisation musulmane pour mener une
négociation entre deux parties adverses
ce qui sous-entend également la
légitimité des revendications religieuse
d'un côté et républicaine de l'autre les
parties prenantes doivent alors
effectuer des compromis pour trouver un
accord est-ce bien le rôle de l'État ou
de ses représentants étant donné leur
neutralité de composer avec des
revendications
islamistes je vais tenter de vous
montrer la fausseté de l'ensemble et
comment un groupe confessionnel a réussi
ce coup de maettre en dupant
l'état si on se base sur l' nique note
connue des RT il semblerait que le seul
paramètre d'évaluation de la situation
soit que les responsables de la
communauté musulmane locale se
manifestent avec une probable
médiatisation je cite menace de sitine
ou de manifestation pour rappel ce
risque de médiatisation est également
important pour l'éducation nationale les
menaces de trouble à publici sont
devenus le cheval de troit d'intégristes
musulmans prétendument offensés chaque
offense se traduira par des
manifestations bruyantes voire violentes
c'est ainsi que l'on vide le délit de
blasphème de tout caractère religieux le
blasphème trouve ainsi sa traduction
séculière et perpertue sa condamnation
la préservation de l'ordre public fait
partie des prérogatives d'un état de
droit alors au nom de la préservation de
l'ordre public ont fini par prener le
concept de préservation de la paix
religieuse en demandant avis conseil et
action aux représentants de la
communauté musulmane on réhabilite
inévitablement le délit de blasphème et
la condamnation par déquipéation qui va
avec la neutralité de l'État en France
aurait dû pourtant nous en
prémunir je reviens maintenant sur les
tenu par Monsieur Darmanin le 7 avril
2022 sur BFM TV il a souhaité faire écho
à notre dépôt de plainte contre son
ministère il a précisé que nul ne
pouvait prévoir le passage à lac
d'anzarov habitant à plus de 80 km
qualifiant ainsi de fatalité l'événement
ajoutant que son ministère n'aurait pas
en rugir il précisera également je cite
l'État n'a rien à cacher l'État était au
rendez-vous il l'a protégé et il
continue de
protéger je viens rappeler que les
forces de police sont soumises à
l'obligation moyen obligation en vertu
de laquelle les forces de l'ordre
doivent déployer tous les efforts pour
atteindre l'objectif visé visiblement il
y a eu défaut de moyens à moins que
l'objectif visé n'ait pas eu été de
sauver mon
frère afin de mieux comprendre ce que je
vous avance permettez-moi de vous lire
maintenant quelques extraits du
livre notre solitude de Yannick hnel
chronique cœur au journal Charlie Hebdo
depuis 2015 il a couvert le procès de
janvier 2015 durant 2 mois et demi
je vous invite bien évidemment à le lire
ce livre moi qui ai pu me sentir tantôt
lui tantôt dans son désarroi d'être
narrateur ce que je veux ce que je fais
aujourd'hui tantôt les victimes de
l'attentat de
Charlie excusez-moi qui sont victimes
sans accepter d'en être ce que je suis
aussi il y aura toujours un lien qui ne
sera pas à la limite de la raison mais
au-delà c'est ce qui me permet non s une
certaine révolte de prendre la hauteur
nécessaire pour comprendre et que dans
nuit sans sommeil on se retrouve dans
notre solitude éude en d'autres
circonstances je vous aurai lu d'autres
extraits je vous lis les pages 132 à
134 le téléphone sonna j'ai décroché
c'était Julien il m'a dit qu'il avait
une bonne nouvelle et une mauvaise
nouvelle la mauvaise c'est que depuis la
repication des caricatures suite aux
menaces qui ne cessaient de s'amplifier
le niveau de tension était monté si haut
que le ministère de l'Intérieur avait
décidé de nous donner à bout qui à moi
une protection je ne comprenais pas
quelle protection Julien précisa une
protection policière vous aurez chacun
un officier de sécurité il n'avait pas
de menace précise à l'encontre de Bou et
moi me dit-il le risque n'était que
diffus mais la tension international
était à son comble le président Erdogan
et son gouvernement déchînent le monde
musulman contre la France et comme le
président Macron lui avait résisté en
défendant la laïcité à la française nous
étions entrés dans une période
d'affrontement sur les réseaux les
appels au meurtres se multipliaient
Charlie Hebdo était en première ligne et
le fait que se tienne en ce moment un
procès contre le terrorisme islamiste
exacerbait les passions négatives d'
après-midi le 24 septembre je suis à les
place beauovau le commissaire françois b
m'a reçu pour me faire signer une lettre
officielle de prise en charge par la
SDLP si je résume les deux chroniqueurs
qui ont retracé le procès de l'attentat
de Charlie Hebdo ont bénéficié d'une
mise sous protection par les services de
la SDLP le 24 septembre 2020 alors que
comme le souligne Hel il n'avait pas de
menace précise à son
encontre je précise également que le 25
septembre 2020 un projet d'attentat
avorté contre Charlie a eu lieu à leur
ancienne adresse blessant néanmoins deux
personnes de l'agence de presse première
ligne avec une feuille de bouchée cela
invitera à récidive comme le prouvera le
mois d'octobre sanglant qui a suivi et
en cela je pense également à Vincent
Simone et Nadine assassinés dans la
basilique de Nice le 29
octobre si je résume le contexte
était-il différent les jours précédents
le 16 octobre jour de la mise à mort de
mon frère la réponse est non Samuel
avait-il reçu des menates précises à son
encontre par des individus proches de la
mouvance islamiste la réponse est oui
est-ce qu'il y avait rupture d'anonymat
la réponse est encore oui était-il
question de caricature de Charlie Hebdo
la réponse est encore et encore oui
alors qu'avait-il de moins ou
qu'avait-il de plus une personne anonyme
n'encourt-elle pas les mêmes risque
qu'un sujet connu une personne anonyme
est-elle pas traité avec autant d'égard
qu'un sujet connu s'il y a une
différence de traitement entre les
individus que devient la notion
d'égalité
je vous propose maintenant de vous
pencher sur les propos tenus par
monsieur Éric Dupont Moretti actuel
ministre de la Justice dans les mytices
du Sénat le 2 avril
2021 c'est toujours difficile de
réécrire l'histoire mais nous nous
sommes dit qu'est-ce qui aurait permis
permis d'éviter ça si je vous dis rien
c'est désespérant mais c'est la
réalité c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons conçu l'article 18
l'article 18 ou plutôt l'article
223-1-1 du code pénal sanctionne le fait
de révéler des informations relatives à
une personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique ou chargé d'une mission de
service public les peines encourues sont
de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et 75000 €
d'amende je m'interroge bien bien
évidemment sur les informations détenues
par Monsieur dupontmétier à cette même
date pour tenir de tels propos faut-il
rappeler qu'un témoignage ne fait pas
enquête mais dire que rien n'aurait pu
l'éviter c'est déjà un grand exercice de
rcture des faits
monsieur le ministre lui-même ancien
avocat au barreau de Paris ne peut nier
l'existence d'un puissant arsenal
juridique qui aurait pu protéger mon
frère s'il avait été appliqué le tout
n'est pas d'étoffer le code pénal même
s'il est effectivement perfectible mais
c'est de restaurer la force de la loi en
l'appliquant pour lutter contre la loi
de la force il leur manquait sans doute
le consensus politique pour que les
services de sécurité intérieure soient
autorisés à intervenir consensus qui ne
semble exister que lorsque l'état
d'urgence est déclaré soit après chaque
attentat et non
avant j'invite donc monsieur le
Président Macron à honorer ses propos
tenus à brut le 8 avril 2022 je cite on
va tout mettre à plat et regarder et
Monsieur damarnin à BFM le 7 avril 2022
je cite il faudra que l'État dise tout
ce qu'il a pu faire c'est normal dans un
état de droit et bien
j'attends pour finir car je ne peux
conclure tant il y aurait encore à dire
oui j'en veux bien évidemment à ceux qui
croyaient accomplir un travail alors
qu'ils avaient un métier laissant de
côté leur savoir-faire préfant un savoir
se taire et au besoin à savoir faire
taire la desence lu été de le
reconnaître et de faire amandhonorable
c'est la base du savoir être dans ce
monde on n plus on ascié le paraître à
l'être oui j'en veux également à ceux
qui choisissent une vérité alternative
défendu par quelques courtisans
cherchant carrière cette vérité erronée
et rassurante pour eux et les maintient
dans l'entre soi on néprouve jamais de
la honte face à soi-même lorsque
certains craignent le regard des autres
le jugement c'est bien que celui-ci les
renvoie à leur propre culpabilité dans
ce monde on détourne le regard de
l'autre ou bien on ferme carrément les
yeux oui j'en veux à ces éternels
adeptes de l'idéologie du pevaguisme
ceux qui sont les premiers à se mettre à
genoux et à regarder tomber ceux qui
sont restés debout se murmura à
l'oreille ah tu vois on a bien fait de
se coucher dans cette partie gante de un
de TR soleil le maître mot est ta bougé
tu dégages cette pathologie paralysante
et tétanisante semble avoir atteint par
contagion l'état tout entier la culture
de PV sur l'alibie à la soumission terme
injurieux mais surtout inavoable pour
être capable et coupable du pire il faut
bien se trouver des raisons dans ce
monde on valorise le sujet obéissant
passif parfois lâche et on dénigre en
qualifiant de traître le sujet rebelle
qui pourtant a agi comme il convient au
sens de la
morale au sein d'une société fortement
hiérarchisée agir comme il convient
c'est d'abord au contraire faire ce que
l'autorité exige de sorte que quiconque
s'oppose à elle s'expose à la
réprobation générale loin d'être
considéré comme un héros que pourtant
Monsieur le Président Macron a pu le
dire le 21 octobre 2020 lors de
l'hommage national tenu à la Sorbonne le
sujet résistant est traité comme un
paria tenu à l'isolement et livré à la
vindicte populaire ce qui conduira mon
frère à être livré seul en pature à la
mouvance islamique
mon frère a était reconnu par certains
et à tort coupable de déloyauté le cûp
de sa désobéissance sera qu'il finira
seul et que l'État Nura pas sa part du
contrat social en lui assurant
protection le dernier condamné à mort
pour blasphème en France n'est plus
François Jean Le fèv de la barre exécuté
en 1766 à abeville c'est désormais
Samuel paatti exécuté en 2020 à Conflant
saint-honorine combien de temps vous
faudra-t-il pour comprendre que la
culture de la libe soit religieuse soit
ethnique est utilisé pour commettre les
pires exactions finalement à vouloir
éviter discrimination et stigmatisation
cette attitude amalgame et réduit au
silence ceux qui pensent comme mon frère
que je cite la vie de l'homme est le
droit le plus sacré qu'ils appris après
ça si je vous dis rien c'est désespérant
mais c'est la réalité est-ce qu'il a que
l'horreur de ce vendredi 13 octobre qui
va me donner raison merci de votre
attention
merci Madame nous allons
maintenant recueillir les interventions
de ceux qui le souhaite sont déjà
inscrits Monsieur Henri Leroi et
Monsieur Jacques grosérin si d'autres
collègues le souhaitent vous signalez on
vous notera bien évidemment monsieur
Leroi pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame peti vous avons été
particulièrement attentifs à votre
courrier adressé concomitamment au
président du Sénat
et au président de la commission des
lois qui a entraîné la création de cette
commission d'information avec les
pouvoirs d'une commission d'enquête
devant laquelle vous venez de témoigner
avec une émouvante dignité soyez-en
remercier quelques précisions me
paraisse utile à savoir puisque je n'ai
que 2 minutes votre famille a-t-elle été
informé associée auou consulté dans les
discussion concernant la sécurité de
Samuel après qu'il ait été
menacé votre dramatique expérience vous
permet-elle aujourd'hui de suggérer des
mesures et je sais que c'est le combat
de votre vie et je le comprends et je
l'approuve de suggérer des mesures
préventives qui vous paraissent
indispensables à la protection et à
l'accompagnement des enseignants qui
viendrai à vivre une situation telle que
votre frère l'a subi avant son
assassinat je vous
remercie merci Monsieur sénateur
Monsieur Jacques grin puis madamequel
merci monsieur le Président il est
difficile de réagir en tout cas de vous
questionner après vos propos tant ils
sont poignants courageux et ils incitent
le respect euh vous avez dit et on vous
remercie en tout cas de du courage et
votre présence qu'il y avait une
faillite administrative politique que la
méthode était mauvaise vous nous avez
parlé de politiquement correct qu'il
fallait justement dépasser et beaucoup
d'empathie moi je voudrais vous demander
qu'est-ce qui vous met le plus en colère
3 ans après l'assassinat de de votre
frère vous l'avez exprimé à travers les
médias dans la presse suite à
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard qui
s'est passé pour votre frère à
l'extérieur de l'établissement scolaire
pour Dominique Bernard à l'intérieur
peut-être un jour et on le souhaite pas
dans la classe on s'interroge par
rapport à cela en tout cas nous en avons
crainte et enfin il est légitime de vous
demander ce que vous pensez sur ce qui
est ce qui a été décidé idé et annoncer
depuis l'assassinat de votre frère pour
éviter qu'un tel acte se
reproduise merci Monsieur grosérin
Madame jacineage brigot puis madame
Mariepierre
Monier merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord Michel je voulais vous remercier
d'avoir dit tout ce que vous avez dit
parce qu'il faut savoir dire et savoir
dénoncer l'horreur avec les bons mots
parce qu'on a tendance depuis longtemps
dans ce pays à ne pas employer les bons
mots et vous les avez employés et pour
ça je voulais vous en dire un grand
merci je connais votre souffrance je
connais la souffrance de votre famille
et je sais que de témoigner aujourd'hui
devant nous tous c'était une manière
pour vous de dire mon frère a donné sa
vie parce que la République ne l'a pas
défendu ça je le sais aussi donc merci
je pense que nous sommes pas
suffisamment nombreux pour dénoncer ce
qui met en péril notre démocratie notre
liberté et à travers l'assassinat de
votre frère c'est ça qui est posé
aujourd'hui aussi alors je voudrais
vraiment vous remercier pour les mots
extrêmement forts que vous avez prononcé
aujourd'hui et vous avez mon admiration
pour cela je voulais vous le dire après
vous avez un engagement aujourd'hui pour
protéger l'école ça je le sais hier soir
vous l'avez fait admirablement à Paris
dans un théâtre pensez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants qui
arrivent dans les écoles qui sont formés
dans les lieux spécifiques aujourd'hui
soit très conscient des menaces qui
pèsent sur l'école d'aujourd'hui et de
demain est-ce que vous pensez qu'on les
arme suffisamment pour défendre cette
laïcité cette école de la République qui
a qui devrait permettre à chaque enfant
de se construire dans la liberté avec la
possibilité de dire et ne pas dire des
choses de critiquer des choses sans être
menacé moi je pense qu'il y a un vrai
sujet et je voudrais avoir votre analyse
sur cette école d'aujourd'hui avec des
enseignants qui se censûent avec des
enseignants
qui refuserait de travailler aujourd'hui
dans une école ou un collège qui
s'appellerait Samuel Patti est-ce que
cela vous inquiète et qu'est-ce que vous
pensez effectivement de l'école
d'aujourd'hui face à à cette vague
d'offensive islamique dans nos écoles
merci Madame sageg madame Marie piierre
Monier ensuite madame Patti je vous
donnerai la
parole merci monessieur le Président
Madame je voudrais saluer votre courage
et votre abnégation dans le combat qui
est le votre depuis 3
dans un contexte qui menace de basculer
vers une forme d'impuissance face à
l'ampleur de la tâche des voies comme la
vôre tels des électrochocs sont des
électrochocs qu'il faut entendre nous
devons le redire avec clarté
l'obscurantisme s'attaque à la seule
institution capable de former des
adultes qui aimeront la différence le
dialogue la complexité qui chercheront
l'intérêt général comment lutter contre
cette obscurantisme qui a pour mission
de qui doit accompagner celles et ceux
qui vont instruire nos enfants pour
qu'ils deviennent des citoyenes des
citoyens éclairés comment redonner corps
à la devise républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité pour qu'elle soit une réalité
pour tout le monde ce sont d'immenses
défis mais préoccupations qu'il nous
faut largement au-delà des clivages
partisan arrivver à relever j'aurais
quelques questions savoir quel est-ce
que vous avez toujours un contact avec
la communauté enseignante que ce soit
celle qui était autour de votre frère ou
d'autres est-ce que vous ils font à peur
appel à
vous au-delà de l'approche sécuritaire
quelle réponse faut-il selon vous
apporter aujourd'hui à l'école
républicaine à ses enfants
meurtris et au cœur de l'attentat qui a
frappé Samuel paatti votre frère il y a
la question de la laïcité qui se pose et
vous en avez bien parlé est-ce que là
vous avez un retour de la part des
enseignants comment se S sentent-il armé
outillé pour la transmettre d'un point
de vue pédagogique et pour faire face
aux incompréhensions qui entourent cette
notion dans l'espace public est-ce que
vous avez des pistes à
préconiser merci Madame Monier alors
madame paatti vous avez la parole pour
les questions qui vous ont été adressées
ça été un peu rapide pour moi au besoin
je vous
rolliciterai
donc pour répondre donc sénateur Leroi
donc par rapport à si effectivement
notre famille n'a jamais été
informé de de menaces que mon frère
pouvait avoir à cette époque-là je ne
vous le cacherai pas que Samuel lui-même
nous en avait pas informé d'autant que
mon père avait été quand même très
malade à ce moment-là et que on n'est
pas spécialement des personnes à vouloir
inquiéter nos
proches parce que effectivement lui il
pensait qu'il qu'il était plus ou moins
protégé que même s'il était très très
inquiet et que il l'avait écrit dans un
de ses mails auquel il avait correspondu
donc avec la principale en expliquant
qu'il qu'il croyait en la justice et que
du coup il pensait qu'en tout cas euh à
la fin il allait gagner grâce à la
justice sauf que malencontreusement bah
il est mort avant qu'il a pu avoir
justice par rapport au propos calomieux
que monsieur schnina a pu faire envers
mon frère ou monsieur monsur sIFR oui il
y avait une autre question monsieur
Leroi je me rappelle
plus expérience qu'est-ce que vous
conseillerez à ceux qui
pourraient être dans cette situation aux
enseignants qui pourrai et on l'a vu
dernièrement encore se retrouver dans ce
type de situation avec V dramatique
expérience mais écoutez malheureusement
je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle la
première attitude qu'il faut parce que
vous voyez bien que le risque est est
avéré et c'est encore avéré ce vend
vendredi c'est effectivement que
l'enseignant et que l'institution lui
propose d'emblé une mise en retrait
c'est ça se fait de suite il y a pas
besoin de remplir des formulaires
extraordinaires et d'ailleurs donc ça a
été fait pour d'autres professeurs qui à
mes yeux n'avait pas les mêmes risques
ou n'en courit pas les mêmes risques
donc je pense que c'est le premier geste
de l'éducation nationale à faire et
après à évaluer effectivement siil y a
une mise sous protection par la SDLP qui
doit être fait
par les services de l'Intérieur
ensuite euh qu'est-ce qui a été fait
depuis alors j'ai beaucoup suivi hein ce
qui a été fait depuis surtout pour
l'éducation nationale bah ce que j'en ai
vu c'est qu'il y a eu des des
circulaires qui ont été sorties
d'ailleurs je vous en ai mis quelques
pièces dans le dossier qui sera versé au
dossier c'est que la dernière circulaire
qui était paru effectivement ENF elle
est très bien faite mais en fin de
compte elle elle ne elle n'apporte rien
de plus elle permet effectivement un
système réflexe de procédure à effectuer
si a menace tout de suite prévenir la
police tout de suite faire remonter au
rectorat et cetera mais en fait tout ça
ça existait avant ils ont fait juste une
fiche réflexe qui permet en fin de
compte une facilité d'utilisation mais à
mes yeux je n'ai pas vu
de d'amélioration et plutôt même parfois
des procédures qui sont très compliquées
où il faut effectivement remplir
plusieurs exemplaires prévenir plusieurs
personnes et en fait le côté fastidieux
parfois empêche qu'il yit une réaction
efficace parce que quand il y a des
menaces bah on attend pas que ça passe
et que ça redescende et que ça mette 4
jours il faut parfois être réactif
presque à la minute c'est ce que je
déploire un feu c'est qu'en fin de
compte on rajoute on rajoute alors que
parfois il faudrait un petit peu
clarifier pour
réussir donc Madame
Brig me posz la question donc pour les
jeunes professeurs qui arrivent sur le
terrain
Z moi je pense que les jeunes quand même
il ils ont conscience de de la
difficulté donc certains sont très très
motivés ils ont envie de porter tout ça
mais beaucoup sont quand même dans une
culture de la laïcité dite ouverte à
l'anglosaxon ce qui fait qu'en fin de
compte ils ne comprennent pas qu'en fin
de compte nous en France on a la licité
on a la loi de 1905 pardon la loi de
2004 qui interdit le le port de signe
religieux et et du coup à la fin on se
retrouve effectivement avec les gentils
profs jeunes et les anciens profs qui le
sont plus tout autant donc l'école
d'aujourd'hui oui il y a un peu une
fracture entre les jeunes enseignants et
les plus
anciens par rapport au nom du du collège
de mon frère il nous a été dit
effectivement peu dans les jours qui ont
suivi sa mort que son collège où il
avait exercé porté son nom donc tout le
monde était bien sûr très content de
nous l'annoncer euh néanmoins de ce qui
s'est passé dans la réalité c'est que
rapidement on a vu que des personnes s'y
opposaient notamment donc le personnel
sur place qui était un peu dans la
crainte et cetera donc bon de toute
façon on a laissé faire les procédures
on va pas forcer les gens à faire ça
même si effectivement la symbolique
était bien sûr importante et on manque
je pense un petit peu cruellement de
symboles et de Figur de prou en France
mais donc là nous donc nous sommes au 3
ans de ce que j'en sais pour l'année
prochaine parce qu'ils attendaient sous
un prétexte que tous les élèves qui
avaient pu connaître mon frère et
quittit l'établissement donc ce qui sera
le cas en fin d'année scolaire
2023-224 néanmoins de ce que j'en ai vu
par voie de presse le maire de Conflant
saintonorine est en train de trouver un
squir qui n'est même pas construit pour
donner ce nom à ce squir au nom de mon
frère comme ça la prochaine fois on dira
bah il y a déjà un squir on ne peut pas
donner le nom du collège voilà c'est
voilà ce que j'en
pense donc après un peu plus loin euh
donc pour les contacts par rapport à la
communité en an donc tout d'abord la
communaité enseignante de Conflant
saint-onerine où j'ai été en attache
j'essaie à peu près de vous résumer
pendant à peu près 1 an et demi où une
partie de ma famille nous nous sommes
même rendus une fois au sein de
l'établissement scolaire pour les 1 an
où ils avaient effectivement organisé
tout un travail avec les élèves dans une
séquence un peu émotion
voilà il y a eu un petit peu un une
fracture de ma part un certain moment
parce que par rapport à l'enquête donc
côté pénal euh donc le l'inspecteur en
charge de l'enquête donc m'a sollicité
ben donnez-moi trois noms de personnes
professeur sur place pour aller déposer
et quand ils m'ont répondu qu'il ne
voulaaient pas y aller j'ai je vous
avoue que je l'ai vécu comme ce qu'a
vécu mon frère avec le lâchage de ses
collègues donc je leur ai spécifié que
je les en informé que de toute façon
s'il recevait une convocation de police
ils étaient obligés de s'y rendre mais
je ne m'attendais pas à à cette réponse
des personnes qui pourtant avaient eu
des discours pendant ces un an et demi
qui qui étaient bien je vous avoue que
voilà j'ai j'ai senti ce qu' avait vécu
mon frère là je l'ai senti vraiment
cette grande solitude donc après pour
d'autres enseignants alors ça j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup après il y a des
côtés assez formidables parce que les
endroits où où j'étais invité à
intervenir sur la journée de la licité
sur les fake news parce qu'on m'a invité
sur plein de sujets hein du coup j'ai
beaucoup travaillé mais euh ben j'ai
rencontré des gens formidables et qui me
réinvitent ben il me tuoi vous imaginez
bien tu reviendras l'année prochaine on
fera plein de choses voilà et eux ça
leur fait beaucoup de bien parce qu'ils
se sentent seul nos profs terriblement
seul et le fait qu'en fin de compte que
je sois là pour aller soutenir pour
aller mener un cours difficile auprès
d'élèves qui vont être forcément et ben
ça donne un tout autre sens
voilà après pour les pistes sur la
laïcité je pense qu'effectivement on en
peut-être un peu trop à nos profs je
pense que tout ce qui est sujet un petit
peu difficile justement ça rejoint un
petit peu le fait quand je suis
intervenu je pense qu'effectivement il y
a des travaux qui se mènent peut-être à
deux qui effectivement des intervenants
extérieurs qui puissent venir en renfort
des professeurs qui sont sur place et
pourtant c'est une idée il me semble qui
date de 2015 qui s'appelle la réserve
citoyenne il me semble je suis pas
professeur mais j'ai travaillé la
réserve citoyenne où cette idée avait
été sortie qui pourtant je pense c'était
une piste intéressante à utiliser donc
des acteurs de la vie civile pour
intervenir sur plein de choses moi je
vous raconte une anecdote tout à fait
autre je travaille avec des sages-femmes
qui elles-mêm voudraient intervenir pour
parler d'éducation de contraception et
elles ne peuvent pas alors que pourtant
elles auraient toute leur place à agir
en milieu
scolaire madame on va continuer il y a
encore quelques questions en commençant
par Husain
Bourgi merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame je voulais commencer
par saluer la mémoire de votre frère qui
était un homme qui avait choisi son
métier qui était un homme épanoui un
enseignant heureux qui aimait ce qu'il
faisait et qui aimait ses
élèves je voulais vous dire ensuite que
j'ai été profondément marqué par les
propos que vous avez tenu tout à l'heure
des propos particulièrement graves des
propos particulièrement forts qui ont
raésonné chez moi je crois comme
beaucoup de collègues et celles et ceux
qui nous regardent comme un réquisitoire
un réquisitoire complètement justifié
contre une institution qui me fait
davantage penser par moment à la grande
muette enfermé dans un splan
corporatisme et qui ne sait pas être à
la hauteur lorsqu'un de ses agents ou un
de ses élèves est en situation de danger
je voulais madame vous remercier de ce
témoignage et de dialoguer avec nous
aujourd'hui en vous posant deux
questions avez-vous le sentiment
aujourd'hui que la mort de votre frère a
servi à quelque chose et la deuxième
question que je voulais vous poser tout
à l'heure mes collègues vous ont
interrogé sur la mesure principale qui
pourrait être mise en œuvre pour venir
en appui à un enseign ignant une
enseignante confronté à cette situation
moi je voulais vous demander est-ce que
vous avez une idée de la mesure que
l'éducation nationale pourrait mettre en
place pour accompagner un élève ou un
parent d'élèves qui serait justement
opposé à un enseignant pouvant proférer
des menaces et allant jusqu'à attenter à
sa vie une chose est de d'assurer la
protection de l'enseignant une chose
étant de retirer l'enseignant mais le
problème reste entier qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire à l'égard de ces enfants
et de leur famille et je vais conclure
chè madame en vous disant qu'à
Montpellier nous avons une école Samuel
Patti qui a été inaugurée en septembre
2022 qui fait notre fierté et c'est un
honneur pour nous que d'avoir une école
qui porte le nom de votre frère dans ma
ville Max
Brisson je suis professeur d'histoire et
donc j'ai été particulement sensible
madame à votre témoignage parce que
lorsqu'on assassine un professeur
d'histoire c'est quelque chose de
parement difficile pour la République et
je veux dire aussi la difficulté qui est
la mienne comme ça exprimé par d'autres
à dire trouver des mots après votre
message enpr de colère et de dignité je
vrais vous interroger sur deux points
d'abord vous avez dit que dans la
période qui a précédé l'assassinat de
votre frère
l'institution niait la menace islamique
et voulait et pointer un
un problème d'ordre
pédagogique cela renvoie en effet à
terrible pas de vague que nous dénonçons
et que l'institution continue fortement
de nier le deème point je voudrais
évoquer c'est la il a été par Jacqueline
brigot je voudrais revenir c'est la
formation des professeurs à la
laïité telle que notre République la
porte et à partir de laquelle notre
République s'est fondée malheureusement
et bien des rapports le montrent dans
les insps c'est souvent une autre forme
de laïcité plus
anglo-saxone qui est enseignée une
laïcité
relative une laïcité
ouverte notre République à travers son
école ne s'est pas construite au travers
d'une laïcité relative ou d'une laïcité
ouverte est-ce que ce qui se passe ce
qui s'est passé il y a 3
ans lors de l'assassinat d' ce qui se
passe par tous les actes de remise en
cause de la laïcité dans les écoles de
République n'est pas le signe de la
faillite par
l'Université de la formation des
professeurs et n'est-il pas temps au
moment où le ministre parle d'école
normale du 21e siècle de que l'éducation
nationale prennent en main la formation
des professeurs pour reprendre leur
redonner les réarmer intellectuellement
en matière d'enseignement des principes
de notre République et du principe de
laïcité je vous remercie colombe
Brossel merci monsieur le Président
c'est évidemment le cœur lourd qu'on
vous écoute et qu'on se permet de de
vous interroger madame
Paty l'association des professeurs
d'histoire et de géographie a lancé en
2020 21 un prix et je crois que vous
participez aux travaux de de du comité
de de pilotage qui
euh récompense si je peux le dire ainsi
des travaux de collégiens et de leurs
enseignants avec l'idée de travailler
sur des travaux collectifs et sur sur la
base notamment de de l' MC euh j'avais
envie de de vous demander quel est votre
regard sur ces ces différents prix mais
au-delà des prix finalement sur
l'utilité du travail qui a été porté par
ces enseignants et ses collégiens qui
sont venus jusqu'à proposer au comité de
pilotage des
projets quel est votre perception 2 ans
c'est évidemment trop court pour évaluer
ce que ça a produit mais quelle est
votre perception à vous de là où vous
êtes sur l'utilité la nécessité de de
ces
travaux pierre
as merci Monsieur le le Président Madame
je dois vous avouer mon mon émotion et
et ma honte aussi à votre à votre
discours que j'ai trouvé d'une d'une
force extraordinaire d'une dignité et et
d'une exigence qui qui s'impose qui qui
s'impose à nous pour trouver des
solutions vous parlez de de votre frère
avec beaucoup de beaucoup d'humilité et
vous nous nous dites et je trouve que la
comparaison est est très forte que c'est
l'équivalent du du chevalier de La Barre
et je vous suis sur cette comparaison
c'est un un martyre de la laïcité un
martyre de de la laïcité républicaine
quand quand je vous entends parler de
votre frère je je pense à cette phrase
de de Ferdinand Buisson qui disait que
l'école de la République elle doit
former des républicains et et c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque
le plus c'est-à-dire une une morale
républicain républicaine qui distingue
entre entre tous et et tout ce qui'est
l'école de de la
République
sur les solutions qu'on pourrait
apporter ça fait plusieurs mois que
j'essaie de porter une idée mais
malheureusement je va pas rentrer dans
le détail mais c'est pas un sénateur qui
peut le faire c'est l'idée d'accorder de
droit à chaque enseignant la protection
fonctionnelle c'estàdire qu'elle soit
pas décidée par le chef d'établissement
par un supérieur mais qu'elle lui soit
octroyée de droit quitte ensuite à la
retirer si euh les faits sont considérés
comme du moindre importance mais je
crois que ça serait pour les enseignants
euh d'abord une preuve de confiance et
ensuite un élément qui leur permettrait
justement de de prendre courage et et
d'aller plus loin euh je partage
totalement votre sentiment sur euh les
les périls qui menacent laallay CIT
plusieurs collègues l'ont dit nous
sommes menacés de l'intérieur par par
l'idéologie islamiste qui s'attaque à ce
qui fait le le cœur de notre République
c'est-à-dire l'esprit critique et la
raison mais aussi par les institutions
européennes qui sont en train de de
promouvoir une une forme de laïcité qui
est la la pardon la neutralité
religieuse mais la neutralité religieuse
ce n'est pas la laïicité
et je crois que il serait temps
aujourd'hui que dans un grand mouvement
national nous puissions débattre de
façon souveraine de tout ça et je me
demandais si la constitutionnalisation
de la loi de 1905 pourrait pas porter ce
message politique très fort c'est-à-dire
la réappropriation par toute la nation
de ce qu'est la laïcité à à la française
je vous remercie madame
alors est-ce que la mort de mon frère a
servit à quelque chose bon comme vous le
savez si ça vait servver à quelque chose
peut-être que Monsieur Dominique Bernard
sera sera encore là donc je pense
qu'effectivement les mesures
n'ont pas du tout été prises puisque
l'affaire de mon frère n'a absolument
pas été analysée parce qu'il faut quand
même comprendre que ce qui arrivve à mon
frère on peut effectivement pointer des
responsabilités à droite à gauche mais
c'est surtout comprendre l'entrisme
islamique qui est à l'actuelle dans nos
écoles et qui prend de plus en plus de
place et
que si c'est pas entre guillemet une
menace de décapitation ça on va passer à
la menace d'une bombe la société est
devenue un chaos en fait à l'heure
actuelle donc autrement
donc donc par rapport donc aux
revendications donc des élèves ou des
parents d'élèves qui peuvent être
menaçants
donc effectivement ce qu'il faut surtout
donc ça retourne sur l'islamisme faut
faut mener un combat
idéologique parce que en fin de compte
les mesure corrective on va protéger un
professeur évincer un élève le mettre
dans un établissement on va on va faire
convoquer le père de famille qui a pu
menacer et qui sera jugé souvent sous
des peines qui sont tout à fait
négligebles donc en fin de compte ça
entraîne récidive parce qu'en fait on
déplace les problèmes c'est un petit peu
comme si on appuyait sur un cancer et
qu'on disème des cellules cancéreuses un
petit peu partout
donc voilà par rapport à ça pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment un combat que tout
le monde doit mener contre l'islamisme à
l'heure actuelle qui effectivement est
en pleine offensive et qui va de plus en
plus
vite donc par rapport à la formation des
professeurs en
insp donc pour avoir côtoyé quelques
formateurs en insp qui eux-mêmes
effectivement sont déjà fourvoyés dans
une laïcité ouverte transmettent
forcément une laïcité ouverte donc
effectivement au niveau des universités
puis on en parle quand même assez
régulièrement on voit bien que ces
enfants doncfin ces jeunes
adultes sont un petit peu effectivement
écartés c'est vrai que je ne comprendrai
jamais pourquoi on a un ministère
deéducation nationale et un ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur parce que je
pense que quand même il y a une certaine
continuité entre les deux et de les
avoir dissociés en fin de compte il y a
un traitement qui est totalement
différent dans l'enseignement supérieur
où la règle de 2000 la loi de 2004 n'est
pas appliqué donc il a une certaine
incohérence je pense dans le
fonctionnement d'avoir séparé les deux
ministères ou qu' a pas entre guillemets
une relation beaucoup plus étroite entre
les deux et une
certaine voilà que ça soit cohérent dans
son ensemble en fait il y a une histoire
sur le pas de vague par contre j'ai un
peu
effacé c'est toujours le phénomène ouais
c'est touj oui
c'était pardon c'était ce que vous avez
dit dans votre intervention préliminaire
sur la période qui a précédé
l'assassinat
de votre frère et vous avez indiqué
qu'il y avait une négation de la menace
islamique pour la ramener à des
problèmes d'ordre pédagogique c'est
là-dessus que je voulais vous
entendre benah
effectivement enfin tout le monde en
parle du pas de vague en fait le
problème c'est que tout le monde parle
des problèmes qui existent beaucoup en
parlent en fait c'est pas qu'on soit pas
assez nombreux mais c'est que personne
les écoute à un moment donc en fait par
rapport au pas de vague effectivement
donc l'histoire de la transformation
donc d'un problème de menace islamique
par un problème pédagogique donc ça
c'est du côté du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale effectivement
cette tournure mais il a également le
fait que et ça je l'ai soulevé que ça
soit donc l'intérieur ou l'éducation
nationale c'est toujours un problème de
médiatisation ils avaient terriblement
peur que ça se sache donc finalement si
on minimise un petit peu tout et si on
transforme un petit peu les événements
et ben ça çaur très bien sauf qu'en fin
de compte on voit très bien qu'à l'heure
actuelle ce fonctionnement effectivement
av visé à amoindrir pour surtout pas
entraîner de réaction de la mouvance
islamique avec des problèmes de
manifestation de bruit et cetera
finalement on dessert la
cause donc ensuite il y avait une
question donc par rapport donc au prix
Samuel paatti qui est donc qui a été
mené donc par la
PSG assez rapidement après son attentat
il me semble de souvenir que c'était au
mois de décembre que j'ai étéis en
attache donc avec la secrétaire générale
de la PHG donc qui sollicitait si un
membre de la famille ou la famille
elle-même donc était d'accord pour la
création de ce prix ce à quoi moi
personnellement j'ai j'ai dit oui où
j'étais effectivement très présente la
première année je vous avoue ne pas
m'êre investi à étudier les travaux qui
avaient été faits donc par les élèves
parce que je ne suis pas professeur et
que je n'aurais pas d'aptitude je peux
trouver quelque chose de très bien et
que finalement ça serait peut-être à
côté du sujet donc je les ai toujours
laissé faire ils ont mené la première
année des travaux extraordinaires ils
étaient pas très nombreux et l'année
d'après ils ont ouvert beaucoup plus
avec Lycée lycée professionnel donc ce
qui a emmené beaucoup plus encore mais
ils ont recruté d'autres personnes pour
mener tout ça et cette année ça a été
plus mené avec ma sœur et mes parents en
fait voilà mais il y a un intérêt à
partir du moment où on fait travailler
les enfants sur des sujets on les fait
réfléchir c'est il y a un intérêt c'est
sûr que c'est pas qui va tout changer
parce que là on va s'occuper de les
emmener à réfléchir mais ces enfants qui
sont entre guillemets
euh un peu lobotomisé qu'on leur demande
de pas réfléchir l'islam politique prône
entre guillemets justement à ce qu'il ne
n'adhère pas au valeur de République à
la LI cité c'est les travaux qui ont été
menés l'année prochaine ça sera sur
autre chose mais cette année c'était sur
les fake news mais il faut comprendre
que l'idéologie qui est derrière en fin
de compte ne et que ses enfants
reproduisent parce qu'on leur demande de
le faire il faut quand même comprendre
que c'est des enfants faut quand même
qu'on essaie de les sauver aussi à un
moment donc il faut bien que quelque
part ils aient un contreiscours il faut
que des adultes leur proposent autre
chose que ce qu'ils ont à la maison ou
dans leur entourage c'est c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui a à l'école en fin de
compte c'est de leur donner la chance
d'avoir une autre
vie donc effectivement moi je pense que
ce prix a du sens parce que du coup ça
renforce une certaine cohésion entre les
professeurs il se retrouent si je sais
pas cette année peut-être plus d'une
centaine àêtre plusieurs professeurs à
travailler avec leurs classes ils se
sont retrouvés voilà ils se sentent
moins seul en faisant ça à défaut
d'avoir le soutien d'une institution ils
ont l'impression d'avoir le soutien de
quand même quelques collègues qui
pensent comme
eux alors ensuite pour la protection
fonctionnelle alors la protection
fonctionnelle d'ailleurs je l'AV mis en
pièce jointe donc en fait elle est
accordée de façon systématique en fait
c'est juste après souvent
les agents n'arrivent pas entre
guillemets à la à la faire passer c'est
qu'en fait souvent à part il y a en fait
il y a deux limites à l'octroit de la
protection fonctionnelle c'est quand la
faute personnelle est imputable à
l'agent c'est une faute qui qui eu au
regard à sa nature au conditioniction
dans laquelle elle a été commise
objectif poursuivi par son auteur et en
fonction d'exercé par celle-ci et d'une
particuliité gravité donc c'est ce que
je reprenais en fait le tout c'est que
on peut bénéficier de la protection
seulement si on n pas considéré coupable
et à partir du moment où mon frère lui a
été considéré comme un coupable il ne
pouvait pas l'obtenir en
fait donc pour la question de la
réappropriation donc pour la
laïcité je pense que c'est pas forcément
dans mes aptitudes de vous répondre si
effectivement ça serait
bien merci merci Madame alors nous avons
encore trois collègues et un président
qui veulent poser une question Madame
Françoise Gatel madame Alexandra bqu fon
type madame Monique dearco et le
président la fond merci monsieur le
Président Madame comme nous tous je vous
salue avec beaucoup de respect et
d'émotion je salue votre témoignage et
je salue aussi votre grande dignité vous
avez dit des mots qui me rappellent ce
que j'ai entendu hier dans dans un lycée
à Rennes vous avait dit perdre l'école
c'est perdre la guerre et hier dans le
lycée où je participais à c'est hommage
au professeur Bernard le lycée s'appelle
Émile Zola et le recteur nous appelé une
phrase de Zola qui disait la société
sera demain ce que sera l'école et vous
avez dit ce que moi je ressens
pour voilà comme chacun d'entre nous
m'intéresser un peu à ce sujet
dramatique vous avez parlé de cette
autocensure qui est celle aussi de la
société nous conduit à nous bayonner et
à faire que nous pensons quaisant euh
non enfin nous n nions pas les choses
mais nous les effaçons c'est Albert Camu
qui disait ne pas nommer les choses
c'est ajouté du malheur au malheur euh
donc moi je voudrais vous poser une une
question et je la pose à nous tous je
pense qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit
on laisse les enseignants porter nos
valeurs que nous considérons comme sacré
ce sanctuaire qui l'école et sans doute
est-il très vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
communauté éducative parce que elle a
peur parce qu'elle craint elle procède
par procédure plutôt que par
affirmation de de de nos valeurs de la
société de la République et moi je suis
aussi frappé de voir comment le discours
que nous nous portons tous ici que vous
portez je ne le sens pas forcément
partagé par les jeunes génération et que
j'ai parfois l'impression
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit quand
nous défendons la Laï C telle que nous
la prenons ils ont l'impression que nous
enfraignions la liberté des autres et
que hier moi j'ai entendu des
jeunes dire que ils avaient compris
qu'un enseignant avait été assassiné
tragiquement mais c'était un homme qui
avait été assassiné mais que il ne
portait pas forcément la même conviction
que nous que cet acte comme l'acte qui a
été commis à l'encontre de votre frère
était en fait une attaque massive pour
écraser notre société et les valeurs
donc ne pensez-vous pas qu'au-delà de
l'école on devrait au niveau de la
parentalité au niveau d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs et toute la société
devrait porter avec force l'affirmation
de nos valeurs et de la République et
cesser d'être aussi timide et d'avancer
vous l'avez dit madame je reprends votre
mot tête baissée
merci Madame Gatel madame borquou fontip
fon merci Madame pour je suis par là
pour vos
déclarations on ressent en tout cas
soyez-ons assurés une émotion
particulière aujourd'hui une émotion qui
va contribuer en tout cas fortement à
nos travaux et j'en suis sûr au sein
aussi de nos territoires je voudrais
commencer par regretter ceux qui qui
baisse les bras en renonçant notamment à
bâtiser notamment des établissements
scolaires on devrait au contraire à mon
sens en faire un exemple c'est ce qu'on
a fait dans les Alpes Maritimes vous
étiez présente quand on appétisé l'école
à capdail le haall du collège de la
Fontonne et d'autres lieux et je
regrette ces comportements de de pas en
arrière je voudrais vous poser deux
questions la première concerne vous quel
est l'accompagnement qui vous a été
proposé par l'État pour votre santé
mentale et votre sécurité et ensuite ma
deuxème question
euh aujourd'hui vous vous exprimez
davantage publiquement et on comprend
bien ce que vous avez subi ces ces trois
dernières années selon vous en toute
honnêteté est-ce que vous pensez que
l'État est au rendez-vous en tout cas
des enjeux est à votre écoute quelle
place accorde selon vous l'état vos
déclaration à vos propositions au-delà
des échanges formels ou informels
estimez-vous en somme pouvoir euh
réussir à ce qui a réellement été
annoncé par un membre du gouvernement un
avant et un après Samuel Patti ou un
avant et un après Dominique Bernard je
vous remercie merci Madame madame
Monique dearco je vous remercie madame
je tenais vraiment à saluer votre
courage et votre trémoyage a été très
émouvant merci surtout de ne pas
lâcher je reviens sur des propos que
vous avez tenu vous avez évoqué le
manque de soutien des collègues et de
l'administration concernant votre frère
et même employé le terme de
paria et ensuite là vous avez également
évoqué le fait que les enseignants
collègues de votre frère ont refusé
ensuite de témoigner alors j'aimerais
savoir pour quelle raison ont-ils peur
de représaill ont-ils peur eux aussi
d'être menacé comme votre frère voilà ma
question merci madame monsieur le
Président la fond oui
madame en en janvier 2022 le le Conseil
des Sages souhaitait que chaque année
dans la semaine du 16 octobre une
journée entière du temps scolaire soit
soit consacrée à à la commémoration de
de la mort de votre frère et et et bien
sûr à à la transmission des valeurs de
la République à ma connaissance cette
journée n'a pas été mis en en œuvre vous
vous parliez euh du sondage de l'ifope
réalisé quelques mois après en novembre
2022 euh dans ce sondage
les enseignants interrogés disaient que
pour 40 % d'entre eux aucun temps
d'hommage à Samuel patine avait été
rendu en octobre 2022 c'est-à-dire juste
2 ans après l'assassinat de de votre
frère est-ce que tout ça ne traduit pas
une difficulté du côté de l'éducation
nationale dans les établissements mais
mais aussi euh au niveau du ministère à
parler de l'assassinat de Samuel
Patti vous avez la parole bien
sûr
alors on va reparler donc de
l'autocensure du baillon alors je pense
que effectivement déjà dans ceux qui
sautocensure il y en a une très grande
majorité qui le font par
peur mais également par un peu manque de
courage manque de connaissance aussi
parce que pour pardon excusez-moi pour
tous ces jeunes professeurs je pense
qu'ils ont une formation tout à fait
succinte par rapport à la laïicité que
souvent on les les jette un petit peu
dans la fausse et on leur demande de se
débrouiller un peu par eux-mêmes alors
certaines fois ils peuvent trouver appui
sur des professeurs qui qui sont déjà
sur place pour les aider les guider et
autrement il y a quelques formations
ponctuelles mais qui comme on a déjà dit
précédemment donc sont menés par des
formateurs insp qui conduisent
effectivement à parler plus d'une
laïcité
ouverte donc effectivement donc je pense
qu'effectivement il faut totalement
réapprofondir
la laïcité comme on l'a toujours connu
en France donc pour ça il faut comme je
l'ai un peu demandé c'est reprendre la
main effectivement sur l'enseignement
supérieur pour que effectivement il y a
un système de contrôle qui soit mis en
place sur ce qui est fait et comment
cela est
fait alors autrement après donc pour ce
qui m'a été proposé en accompagnement
sécurité pour ma santé mentale donc
accompagnement sécurité
personnellement je n'ai pas bénéficié de
mise sous protection quelconque n'ayant
pas eu de menace donc effectivement faut
rester tout à fait cohérent pour la
santé mentale donc il y a le fond de
garantie donc la sécurité sociale qui
m'offre je crois pendant 3 ans un suivi
tout à fait régulier psychologue ou
psychiatre qui est enalement totalement
remboursé mais qui également après
déduit du fond de garantie ce qui reste
tout à fait assez étonnant
et je vais vous dire un peu le fond de
ma pensée là tout de suite c'est que moi
j'ai été entendu par le juge
d'instruction le juge folzer à un
certain moment au cours de l'enquête
donc terroriste et il faisait le point
un petit peu justement pour savoir au
bout d'un an comment on se sentait donc
ce à quoi il m'a demander si
effectivement j'étais suivi ce à quoi je
lui ai répondu mot pour mot j'ai essayé
parce qu'effectivement j'avais bien
d'autres combats à mener que d'aller à
consulter donc autement le avant le
après est-ce que est-ce que les
rendez-vous les enjeux tout ça c'est bon
ben moi j'attends qu'effectivement qu'il
a un après qui ressemble à quelque chose
parce
qu'effectivement c'est un peu pour ça
que je suis venu que je suis venu
dévoiler que je veux jouer le jeu comme
tout le monde le joue c'est pas par
plaisir que je viens ici c'est pas pour
tout ça c'est que moi j'ai besoin de
vous parce que si personne ne veut rien
entendre c'est contraint et forcé
ensuite donc pour les professeurs qui
qui ont un peu refusé donc de témoigner
alors beaucoup c'était par peur par peur
que du coup ils soient eux-mêmes visés
même si en même temps je comprenais pas
mais cette fois c'était pas pas par peur
du terrorisme c'était par peur de
l'éducation nationale c'est sûr ils sont
très très méchants éducation nationale
donc en fait on m'a invoqué le devoir de
réserve que s'ils se mettaient à parler
ils allaient subir des pression des
menaces à bas bruit et cetera c'est
cette menace là qui a empêché que les
professeurs aent témoigner dans
l'enquête contre l'éducation nationale
c'était pas par crainte qui subissent
une menace islamiste non c'était par
peur de représaill avec des mutations ou
bon on va pas trop t'arranger faut pas
croire ils sont ils sont un peu perfides
dans leur fonctionnement
ensuite les sages de la lcité donc ça
tombe très bien parce que moi-même je
les ai rencontré donc je connais
parfaitement le sujet donc effectivement
il voulaiit consacrer une journée
entière
donc dédié à Samuel Patti dédié à la
laïcité dédié à la liberté d'expression
donc qui sont des principes
fondamentaux chez nous en France donc
effectivement il n'en est rien il faut
dire qu'après monsieur papendiaille est
passé sur les sages de la laicité parce
que je m'en suis effectivement un petit
peu offusqué par voix de
presse où effectivement il les a
totalement donné l'incapacité d'agir par
eux-mêmes et qui ne pourraiit agir que
sur les ordres du ministre alors que je
considérais que leur indépendance qui
permettait à eux de recevoir
effectivement des remontées
desétablissements sur les atteintes de
la laïcité et eux-mêmes de pouvoir agir
directement plutôt que d'attendre une
réponse du ministère qui était parfois
longue je trouvais que c'était très
intéressant donc et la dernière question
c'était quoi déjà les hommages Laé
deendre homages donc pour la difficulté
de rendre des hommages B alors il y a la
peur on va surtout pointer la très très
grande difficulté de d'émettre les
hommages donc ça fait 3 ans qu'il est
mort 2021 2022
2023 les consignes de l'éducation
nationale envoyé au rectorat les deux
premières années ont été émis une
semaine avant la date
anniversaire cette année on a battu des
records ça a été annoncé jeudi dernier à
20h02 mê que les recteurs ont reçu pour
rendre une journée d'hommage le 16
octobre donc je vous laisse analyser
cette situation qui est rambolesque
ettendé qu'après de toute façon et il
est vrai le rectorat avant qu'il fasse
les redescentes et que les professeurs
prennent le truc en main ça se fait pas
en 2
jours merci Madame euh je crois qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres questions nous allons
donc lever cette audition mais
laissez-moi au nom du Président de la
fond et et de l'ensemble des collègues
vous remercier pour votre
témoignage j'allais dire sans concession
sur la situation et qui euh je vrais vis
le dire aux collègues parce que c'est
important me
semble-t-il nous avons avec le président
de la fond hier il y avait des auditions
dans le cadre de cette mission de
professeurs
notamment certains d'entre nous étaient
présents d'autres plus nombreux n'y
étaient pas mais je vous invite à revoir
cette ces auditions tellement elles font
écho à ce qui vient d'être dit par
Madame Paty il y a quelques instants et
en particulier sur le point de la
solitude de l'enseignant jeose pas
parler de l'individualisme mais en tous
les cas de l'insolitude à ce de la
solitude à ce stade véritablement c'est
assez éloquant et sur le point que vous
avez évoqué madame mais qui a été repris
par les autres collègues lorsque l'on
nous a dit qu'effectivement de nouvelles
générations de professeurs n'avaient pas
la même lotion de la défense de la
laïcité que leurs plus anciens collègues
et on peut s'interroger effectivement
sur le fait que notre notre laïcité
telle que